about a couple months ago I tweeted that
25 year old women were hotter than 35
year old women and guys that tweet
probably gave me the most like internet
bullying I've ever received in my life
now look if I say if you can't take the
heat get out of the game so whatever
like it is what it is but
these women posted pictures of me called
me ugly and they just these grown women
you know some were actually quote
unquote traditional conservatives
said they had to prove their hotness to
me so they were posting their selfies
like I'm talking like like women in the
conservative movement I said oh my gosh
Pearl I'm 26. and she was maybe 36 37.
Pearl thinks she's hotter than me today
I need to wake up and prove my hotness
to Twitter that's what I gotta do I just
need to wake up and show everybody how
hot I am
and you know this is crazy because you
know the most traditional wives don't
get their validation from me or any
external Source they get their
validation from their husband and that
really signals to me that something is
off where
even at their age
they don't even know what men want men
like young hot chicks guys I don't know
what to tell you I'm not saying like I'm
the epitome of it but I'm saying like
you you look at Hollywood you know when
women watch a movie any any male movie
right when you think of like
Transformers who was in it
Megan Fox and it's so funny Margot
Robbie what when she was at her hottest
she was in Wolf of Wall Street who
watches that men when she kind of aged
out she's in movies for women she's in
Barbie now because women don't like to
see women hotter than them it's like
this thing I don't know
um but anyway so I noticed this trend
again of the amazing wives
and mothers and women of
um my generation and the generation
above me
um seeking validation
um so
there was a guy named Travis on Twitter
and he tweets apparently this is
considered plus size I don't see it
she's absolutely gorgeous thoughts
and Billy says Y'all Scared to date
women over 145 and it's effing annoying
now
guys that lady's fat I don't know what
to tell you I mean she's still beautiful
like I'm not there's some pretty fat
chicks but it's the exception it's not
the rule she'd be way hotter if she was
thin it's honestly like a waste of
beauty imagine you could be that hot fat
and like like if anything guys this
shows how valuable beauty is it's like
it it she's wasting it right so okay
alien America depends on her height 145
better be six too
now this this tweet
triggered triggered all of the women
now
um liberal not Lefty
says the left is 120 the right is 145.
five foot two it's concerning how many
young conservative men's have never seen
a female up close please leave your
bedroom fine Buddies go to camp and try
shrooms with dance talk to pretty girls
do silly things lift now this is a
shaming tactic that I see and it's
always so funny because it's always the
women that are chronically online
telling the men to just go outside let
me see so on the right she's less hot
than the left like and it's so funny
because these girls will put on more
makeup and get a little better lighting
and maybe it's a better picture but I
mean guys the the thinner you are the
better and I really think we've
brainwashed a society our society into
thinking fat chicks are thin I don't
know what to tell you guys um it is what
it is and it's so funny the second men
have a preference what do women do we
Shame Shame insult guilt need to be
right
um yeah lady hotter on the left less hot
on the right maybe a little better
makeup and Lighting on the right next
yeah um yeah no five nine and 143 yeah
and you'd be hotter at 120. I don't know
what to tell like guys like it says it
it doesn't mean you're ugly but guys you
realize most women were like 120 pounds
100 years ago
yup yup sieve get mad ladies five five
and 150. awesome thank you thank you do
you see these are the replies that we
get
I don't want to see your half naked but
you know since you're half naked I'm
gonna say
you could probably lose 10 15 pounds I'm
I'm not saying I I shouldn't either
right but guys it's like we can't even
acknowledge the ideal that's what's
annoying to me is you know a guys can
play basketball
and go to the NBA games and say that is
the ideal that is what we should be
working towards they could say Hey you
know those rich men in Corporate America
or that own businesses or you know
whatever whatever job women you know
tend to like or whatever
um they'll see that's the ideal husband
even if it's not them right but women
when men say that's the ideal they they
feel the immediate need to shame it and
tell them oh no no no but I'm hot I'm a
hottie I'm a hot mom and it's just crazy
it's like why are these wives and
mothers tweeting at this poor man so he
says I accidentally cracked the code on
how to get women to share their
underwear picks online
unsolicited poke at their insecurity
yeah yeah this is so crazy I I couldn't
this just reminded me of my um escapades
you know talking about how the younger
women are hotter the thinner women are
hotter
water is wet the sky is blue it's like
it's so funny how some things I say
sound so extreme but really it's not so
you know because everybody was telling
me Pearl
Pearl Pearl Pearl
um that's not healthy they that's too
thin 120 that's just way too thin
um what was the average weight of women
in the 1800s in 1898 the newspaper
reported that the average weight of a
man was 140 pounds and a woman 123
pounds with the average male height
about five foot six only one out of 208
men exceed six feet tall
so yeah and so I tweeted that don't
shoot the messenger fatties
and what do the women do they get mad
it's like I I don't know what to tell
you if it doesn't apply Let it Fly I saw
a chick that um had a workout picture
right and this girl was an amazing
phenomenal shape she was six foot and
she said I'm 185 pounds and this lady
looked awesome and was she crying and
whining that the men were saying that
women at her weight were fat no
because
she know and I want to clarify she
didn't tweet about this story she had
like a separate a separate tweet so it
was like something else it was just I'm
185 pounds I squat this whatever and
what she wasn't caring about this
because she knew it didn't apply to her
so if it doesn't apply to you stop
whining guys I'm just all right your
fellow Americans are always going to
tell you 145 is normal because 40 of
people are obese in America right now
alien America says he's realizing that I
think the men should keep demanding
thinner and thinner and hotter and
hotter why not
um Ashley Sinclair says I wasn't even
145 pounds when I was pregnant and I'm
5'4
yeah I mean and this is the thing guys
not everybody's gonna be the ideal and
if you're not the ideal shut up like
that's why I think let the men demand
what they want stop like bitching and
showing me your selfies telling me about
how hot you are I don't care like nobody
cares